one of the challenges with building
machine learning systems is that there
are so many things you could try some
things we could change including for
example so many high parameters you
could tune one of the things I've
noticed about the most effective machine
learning people is the very clear-eyed
about what to tune in order to try to
achieve one effect this is a process we
call orthogonalization let me tell you
what I mean here's a picture of an old
school television with a lot of knobs
that you can tune to adjust the picture
in various ways
so for these Oh TV sets maybe there was
one knob to adjust how tall vertically
your images and then a knob to adjust
how wide it is
maybe another not to adjust how many Oh
trapezoidal it is another knob to adjust
how much the roof the picture our left
and right another one to adjust how much
the pictures rotated and so on and what
TV designers have spent a lot of time
doing was to build the circuitry really
often analog circuitry back then to make
sure that each of the knobs has a
relatively interpretable function such
as one not to tune this one not to do
this one not to do this and so on
in contrast imagine if it has a knob
that tune 0.1 times how tall the image
is plus 0.3 times how why the image is
minus 1.7 times how trapezoidal the
image is plus 0.8 times the position of
the image on the horizontal axis and so
on if you tune this knob then the height
of the image the width of the image how
it should please order it is how much it
shifts it all changes all at the same
time if you have a knob like that it'd
be almost impossible to tune the TV so
that the picture gets centered in the
display area so in this context
orthogonalization refers to that the TV
designers had designed the knobs so the
each knob kind of does only one thing
and this makes it much easier to tune
the TV so that you know the picture
get centered where you want it to be
here's another example of our
organization if you think about learning
to drive a car a car has three main
controls which are steering steering
wheel decides how much you go left or
right acceleration and braking so these
three controls are really one control
for steering and another you know two
controls for your speed it makes it
relatively interpretable what your
different actions two different controls
will do to your call
but now imagine if someone were to build
a car so that there was a joystick we're
one axis of the joystick control 0.3
times your steering angle minus 0.8
times your speed and you have a
different control that controls two
times the steering angle plus 0.9 times
the speedier call in theory by tuning
these two knobs you could get your car
to steer the angle and at the speed you
want but it's much harder then if you
had just one single control for
controlling a steering angle and you
know a separate distinct set of controls
for controlling your speed so the
concept of a whole organization refers
to that if you think of one dimension of
what you want to do as controlling a
steering angle and another dimension as
controlling your speed then you want one
knob to just affect the steering angle
as much as possible and another knob in
the case of the car is really a
celebration braking that controls your
speed but if you have a control that
mixes the two together that could
control like this one then affects both
is doing angle and your speed something
that changes both at the same time then
it becomes much harder to set the car to
the speed and angle you want and by
having orthogonal orthogonal means at 90
degrees to each other but having
orthogonal controls that are ideally
aligned with the things you actually
want to control it makes it much easier
to tune the naughty happed attune to
tune the string real angle and your cell
you're breaking to get the card to do
what you want so how does this relate to
machine learning for a supervised
learning system to do well you usually
need to tune the naltar the system to
make sure that four things are true
first is that you should have to make
sure that you're at least doing well on
the training set so performance on the
training set needs to pass some
acceptability affection for some
applications this might mean doing
comparably to human level performance
but this will depend on your application
and we'll talk more about comparing to
human level performance next week but
after doing well on the training set you
then hope that just leads to also doing
well on the depth set and you then hope
that this also does well on the test set
and finally you hope that doing well on
the test set on the cost function
results in your system performing in the
real world so you hope that this results
in you know happy cat picture app users
for example so to relate back to the TV
tuning example if the picture of your TV
was either too wide or too narrow you
wanted one knob - - in order to adjust
that you don't want to have to carefully
adjust five different knobs we can also
also affect different things you want
one knob to just affect the width of
your TV image so in a similar way if
your algorithm is not fitting the
training set well on the cost function
you want you know one knob yes that's my
attempt to draw a knob or maybe one
specific set of knobs that you can use
to make sure you can tune your algorithm
to make it fit well on the training set
so the nos you used to tune this are you
might train a bigger network or you
might switch to a better optimization
algorithm like the atom optimization
algorithm and so on and there's some
other options we'll discuss later this
weekend next week in contrast if you
find that the algorithm is not setting
the DEF set well then there's a separate
set of not
my not very artistic rendering of
another knot you don't want to have a
distinct set of not to try so for
example if your algorithm is not doing
well and death set is doing one training
set but not on a death set then you have
a set of knots around regularization
that you can use to try to mean to
satisfy the second criteria so the
analogy is now now you tune the width of
the TV set if the height of the image
isn't quite right then you want a
different knob in order to tune the
height of the TV NH and you want to do
this hopefully without affecting the
width of your TV image too much and
getting a bigger training set would be
another knob you can use um that helps
your learning algorithm generalize
better to the death set now having
adjusted you know the width and height
of your TV emulation well what if it
doesn't meet the third criteria what if
you do well on the death set but not on
the test set if that happens then the
knob you tuned is you probably want to
get a bigger death set because um if it
does well on the death side but not on
the test set it probably means you've
over Tunes your depth setting is go back
and find a bigger depth set and finally
if it does blow on the test set but it
isn't delivering to you a happy cat
picture app user then what that means is
that you want to go back and change
either the DEF set or the cost function
because if doing well on the test set
according to some cost function doesn't
correspond to your algorithm doing what
you needed to do in the real world then
it means that either your def test sets
distribution isn't set correctly or your
cost function isn't measuring the right
thing I know I'm going over these
examples quite quickly but will go much
more into detail on these specific knobs
later on this week and next week so we
aren't following all the details right
now don't worry about it
but I want to give you a sense of this
organization process that you want to be
very clear about which
these may be for issues the different
things you could tune are trying to
address and when I train a neural
network I tend not to use early stocking
it's not a bad technique quite a lot of
people do it but I personally find early
stopping difficult to think about
because this is a knob that
simultaneously affects how well you fit
the training set because if you stop
early you fit the training set as well
but it also simultaneously is often done
to improve your def set performance so
this is one knob that is you know less
orthogonalize because it's
simultaneously affects two things
there's like a knob that silent E and C
affects both the width and the height of
your TV image and it doesn't mean it's a
bad not to use you can use it as you
want but we have more orthogonalize
controls such as these other ones I'm
writing down here then it just makes the
process of tuning your network much
easier so I hope that gives you a sense
of what our organization means just like
we look at the TV image is nice you can
say oh my TV image is too wide so I'm
going to change this knob or it's too
tall don't turn that knob or is too
trapezoidal so I'm gonna have to that
now in machine learning it's nice if you
can look at your system and say oh this
piece of it is wrong it is not doing on
a training set not doing on a dead set
not doing on the test set or I'm still
on the test set which is not in real
world but figure out exactly what's
wrong and have exactly one knob where
specifics that are not the helps you
just solve that problem that is limiting
the performance with a machine learning
system so what I'm going to do this
weekend next week is go through how to
diagnose what exactly is the bottleneck
to your systems performance as well as
identified the specifics of the knobs
you could use to tune your system to
improve that aspect those performance so
let's start going more into the details
of this process